Northwest is such a Vibe giving her mom
a Kim Kardashian major side eye in their
latest Tick Tock you just gotta roll
with it the mother-daughter Duo dance in
lip sync tequila Harper's such a Vibe
[Music]
and northy jokingly Mad Dogs her mom
it's really fun to see in order to turn
Tick Tock into a full-time hobby at this
point
hey
[Music]
[Applause]
but it all started in secret North has a
private Tick Tock account so we we do
lots of tick tocks together and she puts
them in drafts yeah she's not allowed to
post them but we have lots of tick tocks
I might post one soon wonder if Kim
regrets allowing her baby on the
platform now remember the time North put
this funny fake eyebrow filter on her
mom I could
yeah because Mia I'm awake
see
North this is not funny having kids is
just there's no way to describe it but
it's a lot a lot but we've been living
for all the Kardashian kid content since
the pair launched their joint account in
2021 following in Kourtney Kardashian
and Penelope disick's footsteps
[Music]
[Applause]
let's not forget about all the sweet
sibling love too okay
okay oh yeah shy
oh I'm gonna do some good okay do them
good making a milkshake
[Music]
house is so full but in the best way
it's it's amazingly full amazingly full
and blessed with moments like this
[Music]
foreign